would you rather have a million dollars
let me think actually real quick
intermission no worries it's very
important do not edit this part out it's
important for everybody else to see it
would you rather have a million dollars
or go garage sale for a day a million
dollars really I just wanted to mix it
up at the end for the hook love it thank
you brother proud of you keep that part
in you can help a lot of kids gotcha
you're really good at what you do you
got that down a lot of those kids that
look up to you the first time they do it
they [__] up and then they're like oh I
can't be like him are you putting that
in [__] is everything gotcha that
doesn't take away from the fact that
you're [__] awesome at this I really
appreciate that man